to it to throw the person off your trail
so it makes a lot of sense that we might
see some crazy player for this tekken 7
next set
yeah you can't play autopilot you have
to be able to play
to beat the player that you're so used
to playing so it's going to be
interesting to see how kaiser and chanzo
are going to
battle it out and again this was
something that was mentioned that these
guys are main training partners these
guys play each other
all the time so who knows we might have
synchronized swimming or we might have
absolute chaos
and a lucky chloe kaiser versus chanzo
chinzo be coming into uh my stream all
the time
showing love being a fellow king player
king's got to stick together stick
together man you know
always for the kids and kings together
you know i would have worn the king
shirt too but i had to rep another color
anyways we're going into the matchup
kaiser versus chenzo starting off with
the low period again
start off with the low parry that is uh
definitely a read on his uh
ability and maybe just the player
matchup in general
yeah i'm gonna tell you right now as a
as a king player and mark i don't know
if you agree or not but i feel like this
is definitely kind of
funky for king because you have to be
careful on the up close game she's got a
lot of pokes
that can make you get a little you know
antsy in some situations
uh down for like a down 4-1 you got to
be very very careful fighting this
character because
he can definitely put you on too oh yeah
it's one of those things where you
definitely have to be prepared i feel
like
chloe when the character herself like
you know if she feels like she's gonna
get punished for a lot of things she
probably won't take as much risk
but if the player is comfortable and
they know how to maneuver and use those
moves
could prove to be a nightmare for anyone
because we know what her damage output
is like right we know that she could
really stack on the damage if she wants
to
lucky chloe transforms into truckee
chloe
oh no break on the team wheeler oh my
gosh that's gonna hurt
guaranteed follow up there don't the
playhouse swing no break
oh the blue stuff let me see it in the
chat even if it's scaled you're dead
oh yeah it hit out of the air but it was
just enough and looking at two straight
rounds here for kaiser
chenzo gotta make some adjustments here
what are you gonna do neutral hop kick
nice goes to the low option
and approach i feel like you know the
way that chenzo likes to play and the
way he breaks down his opponents he's
very throw heavy he loves to go for
grabs
however there are so many evasive
attacks that chloe has
that can beat out the throw mix-ups uh
that's one of them there with the power
chris
wow because of the kind of like evasive
sway that she has as well oh my god
second hit didn't get the screw
no punish giant swing that might just
barely hit the wall
just a tip oh my god
swinging to win i like it
okay trying to run it back right now the
four four neutral 2 and getting a lot
more poke-heavy with king that's what
you i feel like you need to do no break
on the giant swing
you better take that ish no oh okay
okay okay all right all right i mean
still it's just a mental game you start
getting hit by those giant swings
you know eventually chandra's going to
mix it up you're going to get hit by
everything else
so you have to be able to react you have
to be able to wreck honestly oh oh in a
counter hit this time
no but the shorter car no don't drop
those
oh oh kyle doesn't matter karate
one more chance one more chance oh
the double alley kick wow fight
all right here we go final round here in
game number one between kaiser and
chenzo
these guys play against each other all
the time training partners
one two or four crosstalk
he knew the recovery puts them back into
standing guarantee that from crouch 402
and look at that big damage here
big lead for senzo can he do it
just holding back no crazy movement just
holding back gets picked up
a little uh not gonna get full damage
but still gets the wall no follow-up
though
oh he's trying to restrict the movement
they're going for the downfall dude this
time he gets it
that should be it the wall makes it so
you get the pickup off of the counter
hit
that means game number one going to
chinzo i was kind of scared though for
shinzo
uh especially early on because it just
seemed like lucky chloe was getting the
best of them in a lot of these
situations and you can definitely see
the
familiarity with the player coming into
play yeah it was two rounds
quick for kaiser right but chenzo slowly
but surely making things come back he
got those two big giant swings
that really put a kink into the game
plan here for kaiser but eventually you
know he
kept chanzo just started running away he
started hitting those down forward ones
he started hitting those down four twos
and he just capitalized on all the
damage that he needed
uh really didn't give his opponent
kaiser an opportunity to come up
offensively to get a flow into the match
yeah we've talked about like you know
being a lot more poke heavy and stop
some of these moves that lucky chloe can
it feels like she can get away with
versus king because of
it just being king so down 4-2 coming
into handy i mean
the fact that down four two one counter
hit was the move to close out kind of
like just puts
validation to it right because you need
those kind of you need the downfall too
you need the down four ones you need the
four
threes right um to you know kind of keep
lucky chloe in check because
if she starts playing it's going to be a
lot harder for you to get that life lead
back because
she's taking off a bunch of damage
anyway so yeah you don't you don't want
her to dance on your grave that's what
you don't want
to start dancing on you somebody time
out what's his name desmito lucky chloe
is honest passing on no that's not true
that's that's not true
shouldn't lie on the internet man people
read that stuff they might believe it is
this king bias coming out steve is that
king bias
look man this isn't king bias this is
just me being honest all right i've seen
this time and time again we talk about
these matches i've seen a lot of
hey steve steve you don't have to defend
yourself i hate chloe too king all the
way baby let's go chenzo
fine let's go all right here we go
my man said as honest as a drug dealer
exactly right
the shining wizard oh yeah the shining
and he's about to
he's about to put some horror on this
matchup
okay what's going to do go for the
moonsault i like it
assaulting the moon what you're gonna do
here this is a problem
area first
jaguar oh my gosh let me put this in
reverse let me see if i can park this
way
jeez and chanzo's so patient he is not
fighting for any of these attempts he
didn't jab in between there was
definitely an opportunity
doesn't matter don't look at the roles
you can't watch oh wow and just a few
opportunities missed
opportunities right there gets the wall
bounce not able to get anything from it
but this is the situation that i was
talking about
lots of pokes far range on the jab
and just really hard really hard to try
to interrupt there's that down or two
again
it still hit oh he was able to stuff the
drive
interrupts the blue stuff using the jabs
to try to keep her honest and that's
exactly where the problem was right
using jabs are all high she ducks under
one she's gonna get a chance to attack
you saw it there
kaiser ties up the set well ties up the
match one round a piece
here we go again just continue with
those posts with that downforward one
kind of harassing
king opting for a reaction here's the
wall mix up
goes for the back turning i like that
though good defense on the side of
shinzo and you see kaiser just going
crazy with the offense
oh butchenzo has
the tackle the grounding pound from
lucky chloe the the backup dancer
oh god oh i thought it was gonna be a
crumple and the quick
standing mid there with the standing
four chloe able to close it out two
rounds to one now kaiser looking really
good here
in game number two big swing
nice launch right there in a shorter
combo to get the wall something
good damage as well block on the down
back four from back turn
yeah nice option there from kaiser as
well able to hit and uh make sure it
lands there after the moonsault
or after the fact that might be the wall
that angle
you might be no and still no tech you
should've listened you should attack it
oh man that's old uh st louis saying you
better protect that [ __ ]
you have shout outs to the bro
uncomfortable man you better take that
[ __ ]
oh my gosh right now chloe working it
here it has a huge life lead
and the launch here this is going to be
bad it's not going to kill but it's
going to do a ton of damage here we have
the wall
what's the mix-up oh the jab
and right there that's what you're
supposed to do because i'm like yo
that's giant swing
that is 100 got to be giant swing and it
might have been but the jab
once again uh gotta keep king honest in
that situation i like the jabs and
i really like the jab as well as there
was a um the usage of power crush
by lucky chloe definitely added up and
added to that win so
one game a piece now one game a piece we
got a big raid here from
you as well thank you everyone that's
tuning in from all over the world
watching
the tekken 7 king of the hill finals and
again we are in the middle of our top 8
a lot of action happening we're trying
to figure out who's going to be
progressing
further in the tournament and we do have
a special announcement later on today as
well so i hope you guys
stay tuned and enjoy the rest of the
tekken stream but steve
that uh that now brings us here to a
pivotal match
where we're going to decide who's gonna
move on between these two i mean we've
seen quick adjustments back and forth
uh what do you think's gonna happen here
in the next match well the thing about
it is that shinzo needs to make uh some
adjustments
um i can tell you right now that lucky
chloe is a character
and she's gonna be able to poke you
she's all always there to check you you
have to stop her
from playing her game um and that's
where i feel like the game lies and
on top of that as a lucky chloe player
you know that you know exactly that
they're gonna be like well look
they're to be looking for my lows
they're going to be looking for me to do
kind of this crazy stuff keeping it you
know close in bases what's been
happening so far
we're going to get into this next game
but i feel like lucky chloe is the one
i'm looking at because
just the way that last game went the way
the pokes worked out that standing jab
at the tail end
but if i am chinzo these throws are
going to add up but here we go
oh and there's no walls here so this was
obviously a strategic pick here
coming from chenzo let's see how this is
going to play out you know
it could go either way king can do
decent damage wherever
you don't need walls that's true to do
it you just need the floor you can throw
somebody on the floor right right
the ground is always there yep the walls
might not be there but the wall
the ground is always there nice good
gets the knock down there with the just
frame the follow up
and one thing i've noticed about shinzo
he doesn't do too much you know
like korean back dash he doesn't do the
back back down he doesn't do that
movement he just walks back he's like
you know what i don't need to get that
far away i could jaguar step back
walk gingerly just by holding back and
still getting the wins i like it
i told you the ground is always there
you better take that [ __ ]
oh you didn't take it you didn't get the
memo oh
[Music]
he was just he was sweeping the water on
the floor you know he was mopping up the
place
i just feel like every time somebody
doesn't tech unconquerable
somewhere in the world just instantly
shakes he just feels it he's like he
sneezes he didn't take that [ __ ] and
just goes back to what he was doing
all right honey what's wrong he didn't
take it
oh my gosh oh i would have hop kicked
you
oh this is gonna hurt too nice block
there
[Music]
now what's the mix what you gonna do
down for it four able to catch probably
could have got a little bit more damage
out of that he definitely believed
[Music]
and again chenzo starting to maybe pull
away here in the matchup he's playing
with such confidence i could see hillary
spacing-wise
yeah what's the break gorilla press
slam 4-3
[Music]
i like the option there and just like
that shenzo one round away from moving
on to the losers bracket
and sending kaiser out of the tournament
oh the kid swing nice fuzzy duck
it's been a minute steve it feels so
good to hear you say that
i was trying to dial it down a little
bit you better hope we don't get another
one i'm going forward
what about harada you thought about her
bro
all right here we go what do you got get
off breaking it you got to break those
swings
you don't want to show your back to
lucky chloe man she'll take advantage
okay nice oh no the punch doesn't matter
breaks the swing
oh counter hit diddy
oh my gosh i told you he's just jaguar
stepping away my man just walking back
blocks the low with the full crouch down
four two full punish
i got hit when he blocked that oh
wait a minute yo she's got the red dress
on that's trucky chloe oh
my gosh chucky chloe he's a killer
oh not like this chest though not like
this oh the blue stuff
no breaking on the normal oh
man steve it's final final round here
one of these two will move on in the
tournament
they're putting on a show for us
and this time converts the people's
elbow no double alley kick huh
old counter combo oh
goes for the giant swing in it that does
leave him right there and still big
damage
no matter what look at this this is huge
he does have the lead but again it's
always scary chloe has
damaged out oh here we go
oh my god okay wait and look at the
damage
you hear that truck that truck noise is
that a 18 wheeler
no that's lucky cloy no break on the
throat spins the blue stuff still going
to get the combo it's going gonna be
scale
oh my god not like this shenzo what's
that noise
get out of the street truckee coy brings
it back kaiser what did i tell you you
should have
you should have heeded the noise that
wasn't a bull horn that was a truck horn
that was lucky chloe truckee chloe takes
the
somebody said who said that in the chat
who said that in the chat you see why i
said that
like yeah man she's fair and honest
until she puts on the red dress
and then that damage it doesn't seem
like that much but comes a lot
and then you heard the horn what's that
oh my god this is lucky because i hit
you with
i feel like i feel like we maybe jinxed
it for our fellow king players i know
the band dynamical esports